he's one of our favorites he works for
yahoo sports also nba on tnt sideline
reporter
and a host of uh posted up with chris
haynes podcast he is
chris haynes who joins us now last time
we talked you said you were going to be
in a scrub hotel
in the bubble looks like you're in a
nice hotel there chris
i'm showing you the better side the
better half of the hotel room
well wait what's on the other side
uh two beds that's about it
how many sneakers did you bring
[Laughter]
it's about one two three i got about
eight pair
you know about two
are you out of corn are you allowed to
walk around you're out of quarantine you
don't have to stay in your hotel room
yeah i'm i'm allowed to walk around i
got here on july 1st
you know so i've been here for a few
weeks already
do you go and knock on the doors of
other nba reporters and then run away
because you're allowed to be outside and
they can't be
uh you act like you seen video of
something like that
have you done that before oh
you know what i'm gonna please
definitely okay all right
i'll just say i won't be doing that
again
how would you describe this scene there
for those of us who won't be able to be
in the bubble well currently right now
i'm at the
coronado spring resort um on walt disney
world campus
and on this campus excuse me on this
property this this how also houses the
top teams in the nba
bystanders you got the lakers here
clippers are here toronto raptors
utah jazz denver nuggets
i believe i'm missing some boston
celtics they're here and so uh
as of right now we kind of share the
same amenities the same
same facilities you know you'll see i'll
see guys walking around taking jobs
of guys riding on bicycles fishing we
have a little river here right in the
middle of the campus so
it's a pretty unique scene were you
poolside with dwight howard
when they had the dj out by the pool and
dwight was the only one out there
no dp i think if i was i would be
excluded off campus
oh wait you're not allowed to be part of
those events
no no no you you can't socialize with
the play like if you see lebron
yes no there's been times where i've
seen lebron and we've spoke and
seen numerous players but uh we're we're
told not to interact with um
players outside of availability but with
that being said
they know who i am they're coming up to
me and they're you know they're talking
and having conversations so
you can't avoid those but you know i'm
not going out of my way to try to seek
contact
how important is the snitch line for
guys to call up
and be anonymous is it real
yeah it's real it's real uh last last
i've heard see what was it tuesday
tuesday a handful of um individuals
called in
on that hotline a mixture of staff
members and players
and so uh it's real guys are um you know
there's been some violations
some guys you know haven't worn their
face masks and things of that nature
little warnings
but uh nothing serious as of right now
spencer did when he of the nets
uh came out and said uh he used the
expression
la work i didn't know what la work
meant chris that's that's the like
players in the import export business is
that
how that works well i just say
dp you know there's work everywhere
[Laughter]
yeah yeah why just uh you know have it
exclusive to l.a
the import export business you know the
more successful
these teams are the longer they they get
to stay
have to stay in the bubble i just wonder
how long before these guys start going
stir crazy
you know it's funny i um the first day i
got here i
bumped into somebody from the washington
wizard organization
and you know i asked him how you doing
everything's good so oh yes we just we
just came here to win and
you know we just want to be as
successful as possible i said look man
y'all ain't
coming here yeah i want to get out of
here as soon as possible
what chance do y'all have come on
uh who is the favorite now that the
lakers don't have avery bradley and
rajon rondo did that affect do you think
the overall favor to win the title i
don't think it affected much
obviously avery bradley is a big part in
rondo also a big part they expect to
have rondo
back at some point later in the playoffs
but um you know
acquiring jr smith you know i i know
he's not
avery bradley uh doesn't have the skill
set at everybody on the defensive end
but
you know jr's had big moments in this
league during big times and
he's also had a blunder of course but
you know he he's a
i think he's a cook for the lakers i
still have a lakers clip
as the higher excellent teams in the
western conference okay and then the
east is it
milwaukee milwaukee's my favorite
uh i can't dismiss boston and uh i'm
going i'm going to mention toronto
raptors because i'm going on other
platforms and not mention them and i got
killed
i'm definitely the raptors they're
legitimate as well the team that i'm
fascinated
well there's two teams i'm fascinated to
see i'm fascinated to see the rockets
i don't know james harden's availability
his health
uh we know that russell westbrook
admitted that he tested positive
uh but harden coming back as well i
think the rockets can be a tough out
just that style of basketball um the
other team is the 76ers
it could be either really good or really
bad for the 76ers
where do you stand on the rockets and
the sixers well sources did tell me
that harton plans to practice for the
first time today
okay so that's good news for them but uh
no i i
i get what you're saying about houston
i'm not so sold on philly i gotta see a
little bit more
but i will say this to the way this
this restart is shaped and structured it
bodes well
for a lot of teams that's probably young
got the young legs
uh a lot of team a team like houston who
can go on a hot stretch and just
go out and uh put together wins but
another team as well dp that you know
that you haven't mentioned and i i
wouldn't understand why you didn't
they're currently not in the playoff
picture as of right now
but the portland trailblazers yeah if
they sneak in
in the playoff picture i think they can
be a tough out first round out for the
los angeles lakers and if they happen to
get past the lakers
i can see them going the distance
well we had chris maddox on and mannix i
think picked
the blazers and the sixers i
to go to the finals whoa okay
i wouldn't go that far
but what i'm saying is if they happen to
get into the playoff picture
and they get past lakers which is a
daunting task
i could see them getting to the finals
okay all right he's chris haynes yahoo
sports senior nba insider nba on tnt
sideline reporter
look at you moving up now your tv you're
a talking hairdo
you're at the tnt hotel look who's
moving on up
to the east side well that's why i'm
only showing you the east side of this
hotel
i was told that you have an ironing
board and you have
your sources tell me that
your your zoom is on an ironing board
your laptop
hey all that is is just great reporting
that's all that is
you got good sources yes i yes i do we
just uh i just had a question here if i
said you could have
luca or zion
i'm going with luca right now okay but
if you're a tv
executive do you think and you can
decide
do you put on more mavs games or
pelicans games
yeah that's what i thought yeah yeah i
mean we look at zion who's what 19
and but luke is what 21 it's not like
he's
an old guy here he's not it's just
the flash and look luca is flashy man he
got some pizzazz like he's not this
boring
you know play i mean he's not this
boring player but you know
those those dunk highlights man you know
people love people love to see zion get
up and down
and we've never seen somebody of his
stature really
get up the way he does i think people
are kind of polarized by that
so no definitely if i'm executive yeah i
probably want more pelican games on
what's your biggest question with all of
this aside from
safety precautions and let's let's just
say that we're able to
basketball question the number one
question you have is
what
you know dp is hard to answer that
without
without even mentioning what happens if
a
player tests positive a significant
player
you know those unknowns will it even be
revealed
like what what would happen um the
protocol but
just straight basketball you know you
just want to see like the lakers are on
a run
you know they were playing good before
this hiatus
does do does that continue how much how
much like how much rust is on some of
these guys i'm
be honest which dp you have to remember
a lot of guys weren't playing ball
during this time
a lot of guys i spoke to didn't even
think the season was going to restart
so what type of condition are they going
to be in and is this period right now
that they're utilizing
is it enough to get them into the proper
shape before the season get here
and even before the postseason gets here
so i always want to see
what type of quality of basketball we're
going to see
you also i thought they were going to
have this the losers tournament in
chicago
or wherever and i is that still
happening the teams that didn't get
invited to orlando
it's not officially called the losers
tournament i just
just like it's not officially called the
snitch hotline no no
but are they i heard the warriors aren't
even going to go they don't want to
participate in this
so i haven't heard much more on it aside
from the fact that
there are teams out there who do want to
get some type of league started because
they don't want those guys
not doing anything for seven eight
months at a time
you know it wouldn't be like that in the
traditional structure of the season so
they want to get out there and
assess their young guys and get the
proper reps so i i expect something
along those lines to occur
all right stay safe don't uh don't
bring in any la work you know you got to
make sure that you you know
nose to the grindstone here no no work
here
no no
uh enjoy uh the situation as best as
possible can you just walk and open up
the door just to
get fresh air i can now
but during quarantine you better not
step out unless
unless you're going to get tested hold
up your best pair of shoes like
if you're going out you want to get
somebody's attention
which one of your sneakers are you
wearing i i'm rocking i'm rocking the
dames
i'm rocking the damn sixes okay i'm
rocking the dane sixes and i got look i
gotta show some love for the other side
you gotta got the paul george's then you
never could go wrong with the air force
ones dp
what about those yellow ones behind you
you know the yellow ones i gotta find
the right outfit
these are dead roses right here i gotta
find the right outfit
you gotta be really good to be able to
wear those shoes man
really good it's tough to get something
that yellow that bright yeah that's like
a highlighter on both
on both feet wearing it now yeah you
gotta get the right
spongebob outfit or something hey i'm
happy for your success
good luck down there we'll check in with
you great to talk to you as always chris
thank you thank you that's chris haynes
yahoo sports senior nba
insider nba on tnt sideline reporter and
his podcast
posted up with chris haines